foreign
do any of you guys know about slot
machine apps slashes or on Android or
anything slapping not slabs like slot
machines just like this like here's
here's one you know you ever get ads my
mom plays that [__] yeah my mom plays
that shirt yeah but then like if you're
not making money is it still fun that's
just that's the thing I wanted to talk
about oh can I can I can I tell you
about what my mom does yes please yeah
she plays this [__] slot game all the
time and I get mad at her I'm like Mom
play something else like please don't
play this game anymore and then she goes
but I have to because you're your auntie
always keeps asking me to play for her
so I guess they all play together and
like she can send like in-game resources
yeah for her you know so it's like all
my uncles that was weird all my uncles
all my uncles and my aunties like Play
This Together collectively okay that
makes it fun but it's also like they're
just pressing buttons all day right yeah
I mean it's just like it just it's
pretty stupid it's hard real life too
yeah but it's like but there's no
there's no money and goal yeah but if
they're getting in-game credits or
something or like they get a jewel or
like a graphic then that kind of makes
sense that's a win like your serotonin
levels
you go to the slot machines in Vegas
like most people are paying like playing
quarter slots yeah they're winning like
every now and then 20 30 bucks but when
the lights go off and it's a sound it's
like you kind of won oh that's enough
keep me going for 10 more days yeah way
after that that's [__] yeah because I
used to yeah I used to get these ads all
the time and I'm like there's no this
isn't real gambling like who's playing
this and I started reading about it and
I found that exact thing like a lot of
people play it together as an activity
oh you know you never win real money but
like this example there's like a married
couple that they play it on multiple uh
devices like every night and they just
sit there and it's like their way of
just hanging out but they've spent 150
Grand on this game oh my God just like
any app game you you spend a little
money to unlock different features oh so
so they're addicted to doing that you
gotta make some games even though you
don't win money it's actually worse than
a slot machine because you pay money
that's why I like physical activities
like if you go fishing with your bro or
even working out let's go hit some
weights and then you're just like you're
really just talking but have you tried
online slots
let me connect my credit card right now
that's true we might we might really
really like it we're like this is why
it's 150k it's crazy though because like
I really was like nobody's doing this
and you looked I looked it up and tons
of people do this yeah it's a big thing
I know that exact game tons of people
that exact one I know that one blue
slots yeah I see my mom play that [__] I
mean in life you kind of take risks all
the time and rarely win right yeah so
it's kind of the same thing you might as
well just do it virtually yeah and then
they're getting loose they're getting
their emotional value out of it yeah
that's definitely real yeah it's like
fortnite it's like yeah you're paying
for skins that's just crazy battle
passes yeah like such a huge market
right huge yeah yeah I've won on slots
like a couple times but never like over
a hundred right and um it doesn't do the
same kind of feeling like I feel like
card games and dice games and things
like that like physically there that I
get way happier and then I can I just
wave I just win more too dude we play
lose more too but yeah when I see the
credits go down so quickly I'm like dude
[__] this yeah this is the worst thing
you got vaporized 20 bucks bro 20 bucks
yeah pretty much and also I like I think
the other games make me feel like I have
more options I mean I know I really
don't yeah yeah but it makes me feel
like I do and then like I'm like I could
beat the casino you know yeah like some
people have it like some people like the
odds being stacked against them and
they're like I don't have I don't have
any kind of gambling addiction to me at
all right it makes me sick to myself
yeah yeah guilty is this thing works
very similar to um they got like an
online leaderboard public leaderboard so
you can see other people and where
they're at with their values so that's
what makes it a thing
leaderboard is crazy on that board yeah
so it's competitive with other people
even though nobody's winning money you
have this virtual amount that you've
like some people are like in the
billions and he's like oh dude that
guy's got a billion yeah it's like
playing the video game at the arcade and
then your name gets to put out exactly
that's me every place I go into has a
Pac-Man or Miss Pac-Man I'm [__] no
way really I try to get in the
leaderboard wise I'm pretty good yeah
but that takes skill to get there right
right but then this it's like no skill
yeah yeah exactly but there's a lot of
people with no skills that's interesting
about it yeah exact leaderboard tricks
you into thinking their skill because
those guys are up there yeah they did it
somehow yeah illusion well that's the
thing that I found super interesting
that it's not skill based but some
people don't look at games like they
don't want to go through the trouble of
having to build the skills they're like
why don't I just skip that part but
that's the fun part well I think people
who are who like lazy kids yeah I think
people who like games and gambling
though it's like one it's the the
serotonin hit but then it the novelty
wears off so you have to go bigger and
bigger and bigger yeah so it's like but
at least for me after
um playing with the numbers and crypto
right when I go back to the table games
like
I was scared because I lost like a grand
in like less than 30 minutes and it
didn't do anything to me emotionally and
I'm like this is dangerous it's
dangerous throw up yeah that's dangerous
because I'm like well you know back in
the day 20 bucks would make me go crazy
of like [__] is [__] nuts and then
like we were just tossing it and I'm
like oh this is not good like this is I
I need this for a phone bill you know
even as a kid my brother I'd be like go
go get my hat from upstairs like no [__]
you I'm like I'll time you
okay I would take off yeah okay yeah get
the clock out that's all I needed to get
him to like do anything for me I'll put
you on the clock okay she'll tie me huh
yeah there's no other competitors no one
for him to like Pace himself with that's
just the thought of being like
competitive he's like yeah [__] do
anything what it's that double dog dare
whatever yeah that that thing
so the funny thing is that like you know
we talk about certain things like comedy
taking a back step or like things
backpedaling but when you look at app
games like in the gaming World app games
is a massive back pedal it's a massive
like de-evolution into just like
skipping all the skill let's just hit
that that's true and it's targeting a
specific type of person that has never
really played games yeah yeah because
even Angry Birds like one of the easiest
game in the world you just have to drag
it and let go right dude and then Fruit
Ninja and then now it's like now you
don't even have to have hand-eye
coordination you just like it's a genre
it's a genre in itself you guys remember
Candy Crush oh God I got into it see
that felt like gambling too yeah yeah
Candy Crush when you get when you clear
the whole rack oh it's like oh
what dude is this yeah oh my God there's
nothing better those are the developers
that are making the most money it's not
these people that are making AAA games
and taking two years to produce it those
guys are idiots you guys can really make
a slot machine just with your faces on
the different right
and you guys just add one noise for
every time like it hits your face and I
bet you would buy it I was playing this
one kind of candy crush style but that
Bejeweled Style game right but it was
also women's fashion wow so then I don't
know how I got it how is it how is it I
forgot how I downloaded it like how is
it both though okay so you when you the
more you win these like games
you can like upgrade your character it's
like
no it was like some kind of it it was
some kind of like makeover show right
where it's like help my house is trash
and I look like trash and it's like
don't worry I got you the present woman
in like a yeah and then you beat these
levels and you make more money and then
you can upgrade her life or his life and
it you could change the house and then
you could interior decorate and I'm all
like I don't know how I fell upon this
game it was probably like an Instagram
ad yeah and then I just got it another
one is that the zombie one where you
build like a City Underground oh yeah
and then you like mine [__] and then you
do all this stuff a ton of those yeah
yeah City type of deals yeah it's like a
survival thing yeah like a little reward
right so like once every three or four
months I'll get it and then I'll I'm
like all right in 72 hours I'm just
gonna go ham as [__] and no matter where
I'm at whatever space I'm gonna delete
this app and then I just go as crazy and
then I get it out of my system and I
don't have to play games for a while is
that kind of like masturbation you just
yeah yeah
you're not even horny it's just like
just to have a thing yeah yeah
the way I see it is like it's either I
do that or I get a console and I get
like all the games that I've been
wanting to play and I'm out for like two
weeks right yeah yeah I unplug my
console bro you gotta I haven't touched
that [__] yeah I haven't touched that
[__] in like like three months I'm still
thinking about Red Dead because I
haven't played it yet all right well
that's damn that's a long time ago Harry
Potter I want to play the new God of War
I'm not gonna there's some games that
deserve attention like that but like
they're like there's times where I fell
for this dumb [__] I was in China doing
work and um I was so bored and I wasn't
getting internet and then I could
download this one stupid game where it's
just a it's like a baseball game where
you're just this character a ball comes
you've hit it and it just goes whatever
distance
but you if you pay money you get a
better bat
yeah you pay the money and it's only 99
cents
hitting the ball so [__] far like
thousands and thousands but nothing's at
the end yeah it just like keeps running
it keeps Auto generating distance yeah
[__] doing man yeah and you can't put
it down like you'll tell okay one more
play I'll put it down the crack was so
satisfying it's like that whole like
thing where you're just hitting you're
hitting something we're getting
conditioned yeah you could for sure
sound engineer somebody into it exactly
yeah do you guys do that whole dopamine
detox thing that people are doing
nowadays where it's like helpful have a
nothing day I went to a k spot last
night for the first time what's that
Korean spot yeah oh you like it which
one you own we spy or no not we spy it
was in downtown it was called Spa Palace
oh I've been there yeah yeah it's more
low-key what happens what happens bro I
went to I mean like first you go with
like the steam room and like the song
that's regular then you go to this like
in the co-ed part they have all these
like special rooms the cedar room like
yeah there was one called The Elven room
the different kinds of like minerals and
then they heat it like Himalayas
the clay room was the craziest one
there's like a clay soil room yeah and
that one I felt like a little bit like I
was on drugs a little bit really you get
hit on uh by dudes yeah some dudes yeah
those are definitely pretty lucky but
you liked it but did it help with the
dopamine detox yeah because after that I
don't want to look at my [__] phone
yeah oh yeah
yeah I'm just so chill now yeah yeah you
know there is a way to enjoy video games
you just gotta balance it out just slots
no no no you gotta go ham 72 hours
you know you could just play responsibly
you know you know detox though huh
what's the actual detail I think you're
not supposed to look at your phone or
any type of stimulation for days Days
yeah it's supposed to be for days like
you just go into the forest or whatever
just it's not only just a detox but you
have to be in like oh yeah nature like
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
like a reset going back to your Source
yeah no scrolling there's this a retreat
called VIP NASA or vipsana and uh this
dude Dave free told me about your day
free is Day free is one of the founders
of TDE record label Kendrick Lamar is uh
like all those people and um he's got
the same gym as me and one day I was
just he saw him walk in or stretching
I'm like yo what's up Dave and he
usually is pretty oh yeah I always
thought this time he was kind of like
just straight dead Pam like what's up
man he's like yo what's up just got back
from this retreat called fipsana he's
like it's a silent Retreat you don't
talk for seven days no phone definitely
no phone he did that as a kid right bro
it was against my own will with my mom
at some Buddhist [__] but that's whack
but uh this one sounds let's pray he's
go there with some monks like you give
them your phone and [__] like you have
like two or three meals a day like they
tell you what time it is they give you
these things but you do not talk for
seven days and then you leave and it's
just like you have a canoe what are you
doing in between holy [__] uh I think
like the guy drawn like walks and I
think like once a day one of the mugs
comes and sits with you and like he or
she like talk to just to you like maybe
like pray with you but like you never
[__] talk probably a lot of
meditation yeah it's a lot of meditation
I think I would love to do that yeah but
he but he in that same moment he was
like seven days no talking and I was
like oh like how was that he's like it's
crazy man I see things differently like
and I I want to do visuals now I want to
visually switch from music to visuals
and I was like oh okay dude sure sounds
good like bro sure enough years later he
starts this new company called PG Lang
and it's oh [__] [__] like Ad Agency
visual like medium and they're [__]
killing it that's so crazy he's gonna
glad you like that yeah I mean like
that's what uh to me I heard him say
that and he was like in the zone and
then a couple of years I'm like oh I see
this looks crazy yeah
[Music]
foreign